these women
are part of the million strong health
activists better known as asha workers
combing india's villages in the hunt for
coronavirus
identifiable in their bright outfits
each frontline worker
is in charge of more than a thousand
people
they check screen monitor
track and advice
to keep the country's rural population
healthy and pandemic free
but it's not just the virus they are
exposed to
they are seen as government informers
and are abused and beaten
this asha worker who doesn't want to be
identified was attacked
while tracking a covid19 patient in her
village
then they hit my daughter on the head
with an iron rod she is still suffering
[Music]
entrusted with dozens of assignments
including a check on maternal mortality
malnourishment vaccination and family
planning
their work now is almost entirely
consumed by the pandemic
and with limited training
as volunteers their own health is at
risk with barely any protection
they are on call day and night for a
monthly salary
of just 50 pounds
we risk both ours and our children's
lives whenever we get back from the
field
some of us have small children who want
to hug us as soon as we get home
before we have the chance to bathe or
even wash our hands
many have been infected on the job and
dozens have succumbed to the virus
ignored mistreated and overworked they
now protest across the country for
better pay and protection
19 has spread to almost every corner of
the country
the poor are most vulnerable
and now more than ever the nation needs
this army of frontline
workers neville lazarus sky news
sony park